HAVE PLAYED UNDER KING.
AND SO THEY JOHNSON AND A PLAY.
THE QUICK LITTLE CUT HERE.
THE RESTRICTED AREA WHEN HE
THOUGHT IT MIGHT.
AND  HIS
500th CAREER POINT.           O
AND WHAT, 12 FEET, 15 FEET OUT?E
SCREENED YOU, BUT THE HAWKS
TIED IT UP AT 1-1.         CLOS
THOUGHT BORGSTROM GOT IN THERE
AND WAS CERTAINLY IN THE AREA.
THEIR TOP GOAL
SCORER, AND PUT IT OUT IN N JUST
CLEAR IT TO CENTER.
17 S TEAM IN FRONT!
>> Eddie: ANOTHER FAST-OFF WIN
HERE BY THE HAWKS.S.FLEURY LEFTE
MOMENTARILY.
BUT HE IRYAN STROME TO PANARIN.
AND NOW PA
DESERVING OF THE QUALITY
MINUTES AND QUALITY PLAYERAND GP
HIM.
FOUR AND STORY THETANCE TO THIS
ORGANIZATION.
IT IS HARD TO OVERSTATE, SAID T
AM SURE THAT THE ONLY
REASON HE SCORED THE WINNING
GOAL -- IT PLAYS CATCH WITH
ZIBANEJAD.
BACK TO STROME.
BREADMAN THERE
POINT RIGHT AT ZIBANEJAD.
D
AND THEN ZIBANEJAD PICK POCKETS
DYLAN ER.
ANLEFT SIDE OF YOUR SCREEN.
MENT THE ROBO CAM.
IS LOOKING TD
HE DID GET THAT ONE OUT.
ATTEMPT
IS PICKED OFF BY KUBALIK.
OND PERIOD AND AFTER
INITIAL EVALUATION, HE WAS
TAKEN BY AMBULANCE
REDIRERETHE PUCK IS GOING TO GED
TO THE POINT.
HE GETS IT IN.
HERE IS
AND JUST -- JUST A NO LOOK
PASS.
PRETTY WELL REPRESENTED, RIGHT?
>> Eddie: BEYOND HAVE SETH
JONES